This is Hannah.
这是汉娜。
Oh, hi, Hannah. This is Sarah from This American Life.
哦，嗨，汉娜。我是《美国生活》节目的莎拉。
Hi, how are you?
嗨，你好吗？
I'm good, thank you. How are you?
我很好，谢谢。你呢？
Good.
很好。
Before we go any further, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Sarah Koenig, sitting in for Ira Glass. And you're about to hear this story the same way I did-- blind. All I know is that it's going to have a coincidence in it.
在继续深入之前，这是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是莎拉·凯尼格，代班艾拉·格拉斯。你们即将听到这个故事，就像我当时听到它时一样——完全不知情。我只知道它里面会有一个巧合。
I have no idea what you're about to tell me, so lay it on me.
我完全不知道你要告诉我什么，所以请讲吧。
So the story is, I was a freshman in high school at Bozeman High School--
故事是这样的，我高中一年级的时候在博兹曼高中——
Oh, in Montana.
哦，在蒙大拿州。
Yes. And I was in the orchestra. And it was early in my freshman year and I had made friends in high school, but didn't really have orchestra friends yet. And we were taking an orchestra trip. So that was a little nerve-wracking.
是的。我是管弦乐队的成员。那是在高一刚开学不久，我在学校里交到了朋友，但还没有真正成为管弦乐队的朋友。当时我们要去参加一个管弦乐队的旅行，所以我有点紧张。
When you're a freshman, this qualifies as a demi-crisis. A long bus ride to Seattle, sharing a hotel room with someone you don't know. But there's this one girl, Lindsay. She and Hannah have friends in common so they decide to pair up-- to room together, to ride the bus together, to be orchestra friends.
当你还是个大一新生时，这就算是一场小型危机了。坐长途大巴去西雅图，和一个不认识的人合住酒店房间。但有个叫琳赛的女孩，她和汉娜有共同的朋友，所以她们决定搭档——住在一起，坐同一辆大巴，成为管弦乐队的朋友。
So we go to Seattle and we're like, it's awkward because we're new friends, trying to get to know each other.
所以我们去了西雅图，感觉很尴尬，因为我们是新朋友，还在努力了解对方。
Right.
没错。
And on one of our free days they send us to the Space Needle and I don't know if you've ever been to the Space Needle--
在我们其中一个自由活动日，他们让我们去太空针塔，不知道你有没有去过太空针塔——
I have.
我去过。
But there's that carnival area all around it. And we are playing the little games all around there and we won Poopatroopers. Do you know what those are?
它周围有一个嘉年华区域。我们在那里玩各种小游戏，赢了一些“便便伞兵”（Poopatroopers）。你知道那是什么吗？
No.
不知道。
OK. They're the little plastic soldiers that have a plastic parachute. You're supposed to drop them from somewhere and the plastic parachute expands and--
好吧。那是些带有塑料降落伞的小塑料士兵。你应该把它们从某处扔下去，塑料降落伞就会张开，然后——
Oh, what did you call them?
哦，你叫它们什么？
Poopatroopers?
便便伞兵？
Really?
真的吗？
I didn't quite believe Hannah about this, but she looked it up. It's true. Poopatroopers.
关于这一点，我起初不太相信汉娜，但她查了一下。是真的，确实叫“便便伞兵”。
I just did a Google image search for Poopatroopers and I'm seeing images of the little guys.
我刚在谷歌图片上搜索了“Poopatroopers”，我确实看到了那些小家伙的图片。
But wait. Is it a generic name or is it the brand name?
等等，这是一个通用名称还是品牌名称？
I think it's a brand name. I think, from what I'm seeing here, Imperial Poopatroopers, maybe?
我想是品牌名。从我看到的这些来看，可能是“帝国便便伞兵”？
[SARAH LAUGHS]
[莎拉大笑]
His Highness? Four star general Poopatrooper?
殿下？四星将军便便伞兵？
Yes. Exactly.
是的，完全正确。
Back to the plot here. Hannah and her new friend Lindsay go to the top of the Seattle Space Needle to try out their prizes.
回到正题。汉娜和她的新朋友琳赛来到西雅图太空针塔的顶部去试玩她们的奖品。
So we got in the little elevator and ran to the top and ran to the edge and threw the Poopatroopers over the edge. Because there's nothing to stop you, really. And we were just in peals of laughter and it was-- we thought it was so hilarious. And it sort of broke the ice in our friendship.
我们进了小电梯，跑到顶端，冲到边缘，把便便伞兵扔了下去。因为那里真的没有任何阻挡。我们当时笑得前仰后合，真的——我们觉得太搞笑了。这在某种程度上打破了我们友谊的僵局。
Lindsay and Hannah become best friends all through high school. Cut to senior year-- four years later-- another orchestra trip. This time to Reno, Nevada. Hannah and Lindsay are in their hotel room studying.
琳赛和汉娜在高中成了最好的朋友。时间跳转到高四——四年后——又是另一次管弦乐队的旅行。这次是去内华达州的里诺。汉娜和琳赛在酒店房间里学习。
And so Lindsay and I were both sitting at the desk in this hotel room in Reno, Nevada and a Poopatrooper comes flying out of the sky and lands on the windowsill of our hotel room where we are-- and we both-- we couldn't believe it. We opened the window and we grabbed the Poopatrooper. And we ran into the hall to try to find other people in our orchestra.
琳赛和我都坐在内华达州里诺酒店房间的书桌前，一个便便伞兵从天而降，落在了我们房间的窗台上——我们俩都——简直不敢相信。我们打开窗户，抓住了那个便便伞兵。然后我们跑到走廊里，试图寻找管弦乐队里的其他人。
We thought someone had been playing a trick on us. But no one knew what we were talking about. No one even remembered the thing in Seattle. And so I, still to this day, don't know why that happened.
我们以为有人在恶作剧。但没人知道我们在说什么。甚至没人记得在西雅图发生过那件事。直到今天，我仍然不知道那为什么会发生。
Every once in a while, we get pitches like this at the radio show-- coincidence stories. Since they don't really fit into our usual every week we bring you a theme format, we've been setting them aside wondering what to do with them. They mean so much to people.
偶尔，我们会收到像这样的投稿——巧合故事。因为它们不太符合我们每周带给你的主题格式，我们一直把它们放在一边，不知道该怎么办。但它们对人们意义重大。
I don't know. It felt like it was about our friendship. It felt-- I'm not someone that believes in God, really, but it felt a little bit like an act of God or something just cosmic and larger than us.
我不知道。这感觉就像是关于我们的友谊。这感觉——我并不是一个真正相信上帝的人，但它感觉有点像上帝的作为，或者某种宇宙层面的、比我们更宏大的事物。
Finally, it hit us. If we got enough of them, we could put them on the radio as their own thing. So we put out a call to listeners-- send us your coincidence stories. And you did. Hundreds and hundreds of you did. We read at least 1,300 coincidence stories, interviewed dozens of people. Here are just a few things we've learned.
最终，我们想通了。如果我们收集到足够多的故事，就可以把它们作为独立内容在广播里播出。于是我们向听众发出了征集——寄给我们你们的巧合故事。你们真的做了。成百上千的人寄来了。我们阅读了至少1300个巧合故事，采访了几十个人。以下是我们学到的一些东西。
You're most prone to coincidences when you're young-- teens or 20s. Lots of coincidences involve your grandmother. You're likely to experience a coincidence if you're in or near the Netherlands.
当你年轻时——十几岁或二十几岁——最容易遇到巧合。很多巧合都涉及你的祖母。如果你在荷兰境内或附近，很可能会经历巧合。
Coincidences also happen to you in or near airplanes or on Craigslist. For many of you, coincidences were the answer to your prayers or helped you find your missing bike. Also, there are coincidences hidden in your name, your keys, your clothes, your address. Like when Flora and Ragaciano Pena first started dating.
巧合也会发生在飞机上、飞机附近或分类广告网站上。对你们中的许多人来说，巧合是你们祈祷的答案，或者帮助你们找回了丢失的自行车。此外，在你的名字、钥匙、衣服、地址中也隐藏着巧合。就像弗洛拉和拉加西亚诺·佩纳刚开始约会时那样。
When we met, he said that he was born in [INAUDIBLE]. And I said, well, I was, too. And then when we were going to get married and we needed our birth certificates, we compared them and it was the same building.
我们见面时，他说他出生在[听不清]。我说，我也是。后来我们要结婚需要出生证明时，我们比较了一下，发现是在同一栋楼。
We heard stories about a lost roll of film discovered, coincidentally, in the stomach of a decomposing hyena. About the man who got his favorite t-shirt back from a stranger's knapsack in Slovakia. About the woman who was dating not one, but two Mark Steven Andersons at the same time. About the student whose car broke down in rush hour on a busy highway and the one person who just happens to stop who comes to her rescue-- it's her dad who lives four hours away.
我们听说了关于一卷丢失的胶卷巧合地在一只腐烂的鬣狗胃里被发现的故事；关于那个在斯洛伐克从陌生人的背包里找回自己最喜欢的T恤的男人；关于那个同时和两个名字都叫马克·史蒂文·安德森的人约会的女人；关于那个在繁忙高速公路高峰期车坏了的学生，而唯一停下来救援的人恰好是她住在一小时四小时车程外的父亲。
And one of my favorites, from a woman named Jill Peterson, who felt nauseated on the subway in New York City. As they pull into the Second Avenue stop, there's a garbage can, perfectly positioned to help her out.
还有一个我最喜欢的，来自一个叫吉尔·彼得森的女人，她在纽约地铁里感到恶心。当车进入第二大道站时，有一个垃圾桶，位置正好可以帮到她。
So the train doors open and I'm beelining it for this can. And as I get there, out of the corner of my eye, I see another person heading my direction-- going for the can, too. And it's all coming up and I'm throwing up.
车门一开，我就直奔那个桶。就在我快到时，我眼角瞥见另一个人也在往我这个方向走——也是奔着桶去的。一切都要喷出来了，我开始呕吐。
And as I'm throwing up in this can, this person who's coming towards me starts throwing up in the can, too. And we're both simultaneously barfing into this can in the subway station. And we look at each other like, whoa.
就在我往桶里吐的时候，那个朝我走来的人也开始往桶里吐。我们俩同时在地铁站的这个桶里呕吐。我们看着对方，心想，哇。
I don't know. How are you feeling? She's like, oh, I'm feeling a little bit better now. I'm like, me, too.
我不知道。你感觉怎么样？她说，哦，我现在感觉好多了。我说，我也是。
What's the only way to survive throwing up in front of a subway car full of strangers? Have a nice girl your age do it with you. And numbers-- so many coincidences with numbers. One woman told us how she was at Thanksgiving with her extended family and they suddenly realized that six of them had the exact same number of letters in their names-- 23 letters.
在满车陌生人面前呕吐，唯一的生存方式是什么？找个同龄的漂亮女孩和你一起吐。还有数字——关于数字的巧合太多了。一位女士告诉我们，她感恩节和大家庭在一起时，突然意识到他们中有六个人的名字里的字母数量完全相同——都是23个字母。
Michael Arthur van de Putte, Mary Elizabeth van de Putte, William Arthur van de Putte--
迈克尔·亚瑟·范德普特，玛丽·伊丽莎白·范德普特，威廉·亚瑟·范德普特——
There was the guy at the mall doing surveys who had to ask people their phone number. It's obvious the guy he's surveying starts to make up a number. He says, 933- 45-- 6--
还有一个在商场做调查的家伙，必须问人们的电话号码。显而易见，被调查的那个家伙开始胡编一个号码。他说，933-45--6--
When he read out that last number, he said, 8? And I stepped back for a second, but I was cool. And I said, no, sir. I'm sorry. That's not your phone number.
当他念出最后一个数字时，他说，8？我退后了一步，但我很冷静。我说，不，先生。对不起。那不是你的电话号码。
And he said, why isn't that my phone number? And I said, because that's my phone number. That's my phone number. The phone number that you just made up is actually my phone number.
他说，为什么那不是我的电话号码？我说，因为那是我的电话号码。那是我的电话号码。你刚才胡编的那个电话号码实际上是我的电话号码。
These stories reminded me of an old Chinese saying I once heard. Actually, I learned it a couple of weeks ago and I have no idea how old it is. But it goes like this.
这些故事让我想起了一句我曾经听过的古老中国谚语。其实，我是几周前才学到的，我完全不知道它有多古老。它是这样说的。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
That's my friend, Yuen Yuen Di.
那是我的朋友，袁元娣。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
And what does it mean?
那是什么意思？
If there's no coincidence, there won't be stories.
无巧不成书。
No coincidence, no story.
没有巧合，就没有故事。
To imply that of course, lives are all-- I don't know-- developed in ways that we can't predict.
意思是，当然，生活的发展方式是我们无法预测的。
So is it like, if you heard a story with a coincidence, afterwards, you might be like, no coincidence, no story-- like that?
所以，如果听到一个有巧合的故事，事后你会说，“无巧不成书”——是这样吗？
That's right. Yes. Just an expression you use that you quote.
没错。是的。这只是你引用的一个表达。
Is it a corny thing to say?
说这句话会显得很老土吗？
Mostly, I think no. It won't be a corny thing to say.
大部分情况下，我认为不会。说这句话不会显得老土。
Do you ever use it?
你用过吗？
When I'm corny, yes.
当我表现得老土时，会用。
At the risk of being corny, I'm going to say it. Today's show-- no coincidence, no story. While the big man's away, we're going to sneak these coincidence stories onto the air. All the stories you'll hear today first aired on our show in 2013. And they're all verified true stories that my colleagues hid from me until the actual interviews so it wouldn't spoil the surprise, which is also why there is so much unprofessional giggling this hour. And full disclosure, I came into this topic a coincidence skeptic, believing that a coincidence is just a coincidence-- nothing more. I judged, I confronted weakness, I countered wide-eyed faith with statistical probability. And by the end, well, stay with us.
冒着老土的风险，我还是要说。今天的节目——无巧不成书。趁大老板不在，我们要悄悄把这些巧合故事播出。你们今天听到的所有故事都曾在我们2013年的节目中播出过。它们都是经过核实的真实故事，同事们一直对我保密，直到采访现场才揭晓，以免破坏惊喜，这也是为什么这一小时里有那么多不专业的咯咯笑。坦白说，我在处理这个话题时是一个巧合怀疑论者，认为巧合就是巧合——仅此而已。我曾评判过，对抗过软弱，用统计概率对抗过那些睁大眼睛的信仰。但到了最后，嗯，留下来听听吧。
Act One, Grandmas. Blake Oliver is living in Nicaragua right now. We talked on Skype. About four months ago, he was on the phone to his friend Camille, who goes by Cami. He mentioned to her that the screen saver on his iPhone had been the same picture for a long time-- that he wanted to change it.
第一幕，祖母们。布雷克·奥利弗现在住在尼加拉瓜。我们通过Skype聊了聊。大约四个月前，他在电话里和朋友卡米尔（大家都叫她卡米）聊天。他提到他iPhone上的屏保一直是同一张照片，很久没变了——他想换掉它。
So I asked her to just send me a picture of something. And it was really funny. She ended up sending me this picture of her as a little kid as a joke.
所以我让她随便发一张照片给我。这很有趣。她最终开玩笑地发了一张她小时候的照片给我。
And I was like, oh, yeah. That's kind of funny. It was not what I was expecting, but that's funny. And then I glanced back at the picture and I saw my grandma walking through behind her.
我说，哦，是的。这挺有趣的。不是我预期的，但这很有趣。然后我又瞥了一眼那张照片，看到我的祖母在她身后经过。
What?
什么？
Yeah. How crazy is that, right?
是的。多疯狂啊，对吧？
Very crazy. The picture was taken about 18 years ago.
非常疯狂。那张照片是大约18年前拍的。
But you recognized her right away.
但你立刻认出了她。
Oh, absolutely. There was no question that was Grandma Joyce. It was, without question, Grandma Joyce.
哦，当然。毫无疑问那是乔伊斯祖母。毫无疑问，那就是乔伊斯祖母。
Coincidences like this one usually have a dense nest of details to bolster the craziness. Here goes. Blake is from Michigan. That's where he met Camille. But Camille's family isn't from Michigan at all.
像这样的巧合通常有一堆密集的细节来支撑其疯狂程度。听好了。布雷克来自密歇根州。他就是在那里遇见卡米尔的。但卡米尔的家人根本不是密歇根人。
They're originally from Utah-- Salt Lake City, Utah.
他们最初来自犹他州——犹他州盐湖城。
That's where she grew up.
那是她长大的地方。
Yeah. That's where she grew up.
是的，那是她长大的地方。
Was this photo from Utah?
这张照片是在犹他州拍的吗？
No. And that's-- the funny thing is my grandma lives in Melbourne, Florida. And I'm thinking, oh, she must have been in Utah and walked past it.
不。有趣的是，我的祖母住在佛罗里达州的墨尔本。我当时想，哦，她肯定当时在犹他州，然后从那儿经过。
Cami's like, no, no. That picture was taken in Parksville, Vancouver Island, in Canada.
卡米说，不，不。那张照片是在加拿大的温哥华岛帕克斯维尔拍的。
What?
什么？
Yeah, right?
是的，对吧？
Blake figured out that at the same time that Cami and her family were on vacation in Vancouver, Grandma Joyce had gone there to visit some of her husband's relatives.
布雷克推测，就在卡米和她的家人在温哥华度假的同时，乔伊斯祖母也去那里探望她丈夫的一些亲戚。
What are the chances to think that not only did I meet Cami, but she sends me this picture of her in the background-- of my grandma?
谁能想到，不仅我遇到了卡米，而且她发给我的这张照片背景里居然有我的祖母？
I don't know what the chances are. Minuscule.
我不知道概率是多少。微乎其微。
Right?
对吧？
Yes!
是的！
And not only-- I don't know if you've seen the picture. But not only just in the picture, but perfectly behind her.
而且不仅——不知道你有没有看过那张照片。她不仅在照片里，而且正好就在她身后。
At that moment, a fellow producer emailed me the photo. And there it was-- cute, four-year-old Cami in the foreground, facing the camera. And not far behind her, a blonde woman walking past wearing blue shorts and a matching top.
就在那一刻，一位同事给我发来了这张照片。照片就在那里——前景是可爱的四岁卡米，正对着镜头。在她身后不远处，一个金发女人穿着蓝色短裤和配套上衣走过。
Yeah. And she has no idea that she's in the picture even.
是的。她甚至完全不知道自己出现在照片里。
Yeah, right. It's not like-- yeah. She doesn't seem aware. But I have to say, it's a little-- it's not a very crisp photo. I'm surprised you would recognize her right away.
是的，没错。她看起来并不知情。但我不得不说，这照片不是很清晰。我很惊讶你能立刻认出她。
Well, yeah. There's not a lot of-- it's my grandma. I don't know. It's like--
嗯，是的。虽然没有很多细节——但那是我的祖母。我不知道。就好像——
[SARAH LAUGHS]
[莎拉大笑]
20 years ago, for my first reporting job, I interviewed a woman who'd just turned 100 years old. I asked her, admittedly, a rookie question-- what's the most amazing thing that's happened in your life?
20年前，在我第一份新闻工作中，我采访了一位刚满100岁的老妇人。我问了一个公认的菜鸟问题——你一生中发生过最神奇的事情是什么？
She thought for a while and then she said, the most interesting thing that happened to me was that on my first day at Patrog School, the principal said to me, what's your name? I said, Esther Tuttle. And he said, I have a friend in Shelter Island by that name. I was 12, she said. And that, to me, was remarkable.
她想了一会儿，然后说，我一生中最有趣的事情是，我在帕特罗格学校的第一天，校长问我，你叫什么名字？我说，艾丝特·塔特尔。他说，我在谢尔特岛有个朋友也叫这个名字。她说，那时我12岁。对我来说，那非常了不起。
This woman had seen the advent of cars and movies and computers and space travel, and this was her answer. At the time, I thought it was lame-- that maybe Esther was losing it a little. But since I started hearing all these coincidence stories the last couple of weeks, I've reconsidered. Coincidences feels so rare, and that sticks with you, even when the coincidence is barely a coincidence at all.
这位老妇人见证了汽车、电影、计算机和太空旅行的出现，这就是她的答案。当时，我觉得这很无聊——也许艾丝特有点神志不清了。但自从我过去几周开始听到所有这些巧合故事后，我重新考虑了。巧合感觉太稀少了，所以它会一直留在你脑海里，即使那个巧合勉强算不上巧合。
An academic study of people's reactions to coincidence stories from the early 1980s found that we have an egocentric bias toward our own coincidences. That people find stories that happened to them far more surprising than the same stories happening to other people. Case in point.
20世纪80年代早期一项关于人们对巧合故事反应的学术研究发现，我们对自己遇到的巧合有一种自我中心偏见。人们认为发生在自己身上的故事远比同样发生在别人身上的故事令人惊讶得多。举个例子。
My name is Juliana Bontrager and I'm 16 years old.
我叫朱莉安娜·邦特雷格，今年16岁。
Juliana-- she's got a problem with her grandmother.
朱莉安娜——她对她的祖母有些看法。
My grandma has been obsessed with coincidences. And she finds them in her life all the time and she always wants to tell everyone about them. And we get annoyed with her sometimes because she thinks they're so incredible and how they happen to her all the time. And every time we see her-- oh, my gosh. You would not believe what happened to me.
我祖母一直沉迷于巧合。她总是在生活中发现巧合，而且总是想告诉每个人。我们有时会觉得她很烦，因为她觉得这些事情太不可思议了，而且它们一直在她身上发生。每次我们见到她——噢，天哪。你绝对不敢相信刚才发生了什么。
And I always-- I was at the hospital with-- she lives with her cousin so she takes her cousin to the doctor's office quite a bit for appointments and stuff. And she'll be sitting in the waiting room. And then they'll drive to go get lunch after that and they'll see the people they were waiting in the waiting room with at the restaurant.
我总是——我和她一起在医院——她和她的表亲住在一起，所以她经常带她的表亲去医生办公室看病之类的事情。她会坐在候诊室里。后来他们开车去吃午饭，在餐馆里又看见了在候诊室一起等候的人。
And I always thought that was funny. Because it's like, yeah, that's coincidence. But maybe they're just going to get lunch, too. It's not that big of a deal.
我一直觉得这很好笑。因为，嗯，这就是巧合。但也许他们也只是去吃午饭。这没什么大不了的。
Yeah.
是的。
So then, a while ago, I was doing a project in my English class. We were reading The Scarlet Letter book. And I was-- once we finished the book, our end project was we had to come up with what our sin was or what sin we struggled with the most. And I chose envy.
所以，不久前，我在做英语课的课题。我们正在读《红字》这本书。读完书后，我们要做的期末项目是，找出我们的罪恶是什么，或者我们挣扎最多的罪恶是什么。我选择了嫉妒。
So we had to create our own letter out of paper and then we had to safety pin it to our shirt and wear it around school the entire day. So as I was coloring in my letter and cutting it out, my mom was listening to the show Monk in the background.
我们要用纸剪出自己的字母，然后用别针别在衬衫上，在学校戴上一整天。就在我给字母上色并把它剪下来的时候，我妈妈正在后台听《神探阿蒙》这部剧。
As we were watching it, I was literally cutting out my last line on the letter E for envy. And it said, on the show, I've studied the seven sins and the most prominent one is envy, as I was cutting out my letter. And so I immediately called my grandma and was telling her about it.
当我们在看剧时，我真的正在剪字母E（嫉妒，Envy）的最后一条线。剧里说，我研究了七宗罪，最突出的一宗是嫉妒，正好就在我剪我的字母时。于是我立刻打电话给祖母告诉她这件事。
And she was like, oh, uh-huh. That's a good one. Yeah. And then I didn't really hear back from her after that. And I thought, well, maybe she's just envious of my great coincidence.
她说，哦，嗯哼。那真不错。是的。然后之后就没怎么收到她的回音。我想，好吧，也许她只是嫉妒我这个伟大的巧合。
[SARAH LAUGHS]
[莎拉大笑]
And I was sitting there like, are you kidding? Mine was so much better. You just happened to run into a person twice in one day. I do that all the time. What are the odds of, as I'm cutting out this letter E, they would talk about that on a show? And I was so confused about it.
我坐在那里心想，你在开玩笑吗？我的比你的好多了。你只是碰巧一天内遇到同一个人两次。我经常这样做。我在剪这个字母E的时候，他们正好在节目里谈论这个，概率有多大？我对此感到非常困惑。
OK. So Juliana's coincidence is a common one. We've all had those moments when you're reading a certain word and then someone says it on the radio or on TV. But remember, Juliana's 16, so maybe this is the first time it's happening to her. Still, I'm on her side here. I think it is more remarkable than her grandmother's example of the people in the waiting room being at the restaurant.
好吧。所以朱莉安娜的巧合很常见。我们都曾有过那种正在读某个词，然后电台或电视里就正好说出那个词的时刻。但请记住，朱莉安娜才16岁，所以这可能是她第一次遇到这种事。尽管如此，我站在她这一边。我认为这确实比她祖母提到的在餐馆遇到候诊室里的人的例子更了不起。
Do you have a phone where you can dial up your grandma right now?
你现在能用手机给你祖母打个电话吗？
I can try.
我可以试试。
Try it.
试试吧。
OK. One second.
好的，等一下。
So Juliana conferenced her grandmother in so we could settle this.
于是朱莉安娜通过电话连线了她的祖母，这样我们就能解决这个争论。
I'm here. Elaine Olson.
我在。我是伊莱恩·奥尔森。
Elaine Olson. Nice to meet you.
伊莱恩·奥尔森。很高兴见到你。
Nice to meet you, dear.
很高兴见到你，亲爱的。
I laid out my argument for Elaine about the purity-- and therefore, superiority-- of Juliana's example. But Elaine argued right back. There were several hours between the two sitings, plus, the restaurant was about four miles from the hospital.
我向伊莱恩陈述了我的论点，关于朱莉安娜例子的纯粹性——因此是优越性。但伊莱恩立刻反驳了回来。两次相遇之间隔了好几个小时，而且餐馆离医院大约有四英里。
And in that four mile radius, you might say, I could have gone to any number of restaurants. The fact that I ran into her at that restaurant, I think is a coincidence.
在那四英里的范围内，你可能会说，我可以去很多餐厅。我认为我在那家餐厅碰到她是一个巧合。
I think--
我想——
She could have gone any place, too.
她也可以去任何地方。
That's true. It's true. I'm not saying it's not a coincidence, I'm just saying it's not maybe as pure as-- you can break down the probabilities of a certain kind of person in a certain kind of neighborhood going--
那是真的。确实。我不是说这不是巧合，我只是说它可能没有那么纯粹——你可以分解概率，比如某种人在某种社区去某个地方——
I don't think so.
我不这么认为。
You don't think so.
你不这么认为。
I don't think so. I think that is--
我不这么认为。我认为那是——
Do you think you're somehow prone to coincidences-- like coincidences find you more than they find other people?
你觉得你是否特别容易遇到巧合——就像巧合比其他人更容易找到你一样？
I don't know. That's why-- in my own family-- I've asked them, does this happen to you? And don't get much of a response. But--
我不知道。这就是为什么——在我自己的家庭里——我问过他们，这会发生在你们身上吗？没有得到什么回应。但是——
You are impossible to argue with. So when you ask for coincidences, we have nothing to give to you because you have-- you are so set in your ways.
你真是让人无法辩驳。所以当我们征集巧合时，我们什么也给不了你，因为你——你太固执己见。
I'm 81. OK. Yeah. OK.
我81岁了。好吧。是的。好吧。
So what would Juliana have to experience, in terms of a coincidence, that would impress you, do you think? What would it need to be?
那么，朱莉安娜经历什么样的巧合才能打动你呢？你认为需要是什么样的？
Well, it's hard to tell. Just a couple of weeks ago, I had my cousin up at another doctor's. I'm sitting in the reception area. Gentlemen across from me was Asian and--
嗯，很难说。就在几周前，我带着我的表亲去另一位医生那里。我坐在接待区。对面的一位绅士是亚洲人，而且——
This time it was about an Asian man in the waiting room whom she later saw buying a melon at Trader Joe's, which Elaine admitted wasn't as good as the other one.
这次是关于她在候诊室遇到的一位亚洲男士，后来她在Trader Joe's超市买瓜时又看到了他，伊莱恩承认这确实不如上一个巧合好。
Act Two, In God We Trust. It's probably no surprise that we got a huge number of coincidence pitches about love-- romantic love. A few years ago, after Stephen Lee proposed to his girlfriend Helen, they brought their families together for the first time to celebrate the engagement.
第二幕，我们信仰上帝。我们收到大量关于爱情——浪漫爱情的巧合投稿，这可能并不奇怪。几年前，在斯蒂芬·李向女友海伦求婚后，他们第一次把双方家庭聚在一起庆祝订婚。
My mom and my stepdad came to New York to meet with Helen's parents. And basically, over the course of dinner and coffee afterwards, we discovered that, basically, my father had dated my wife's mother back in Korea back in the 1960s and he had proposed to her--
我妈妈和继父来到纽约见海伦的父母。基本上，在晚餐和随后的咖啡时间里，我们发现，我父亲竟然在20世纪60年代在韩国和妻子的母亲约会过，而且他向她求婚了——
I'm going to slow this down a sec, just to let it sink in. Helen's mother had almost married Stephen's father-- his late father, actually. He died when Stephen was 17. And how this all came out was that after they had dinner, they went back to Stephen's apartment and they were looking at Stephen's family photographs.
我慢一点，让大家消化一下这个信息。海伦的母亲差点就嫁给了斯蒂芬的父亲——实际上是他已故的父亲。他在斯蒂芬17岁时去世了。事情的起因是，他们吃完晚饭回到斯蒂芬的公寓，正在看斯蒂芬的家庭相册。
So my future mother-in-law's flipping through the album and she sees my dad. And so she asks, oh, oh, what was his name? And my mom tells the name. And my future mother-in-law just nods and moves on and keeps on flipping through the book-- doesn't even say anything.
我未来的岳母翻着相册看到了我爸爸。她问，哦，哦，他叫什么名字？我妈说了名字。我未来的岳母只是点了点头，继续翻书——什么也没说。
Imagine what she must've been feeling with seeing that photo suddenly-- just flooded.
想象一下，她突然看到那张照片时是什么心情——瞬间被淹没了。
Yeah.
是啊。
Crazy.
疯狂。
She has a-- she just must-- I think she'd be really good at poker.
她一定——我想她一定非常擅长玩扑克。
(LAUGHING) Right.
（大笑）没错。
So Helen's mother says nothing, goes home. But later that night, she tells her daughter, this was the one. This was the man who might have been. She explained that the reason they hadn't married was because her father-- Helen's grandfather-- had chosen a different husband for her-- the man who became Helen's father. All of them ended up living in the US, but they quickly lost touch. And Stephen didn't find out about any of this until a couple of days later.
海伦的母亲什么也没说，回家了。但那天晚些时候，她告诉女儿，这就是那个男人。这就是那个本可能成为我丈夫的人。她解释说，他们没有结婚的原因是她的父亲——海伦的外祖父——为她选了另一个丈夫——也就是后来成为海伦父亲的那个男人。他们最终都住在美国，但很快就失去了联系。斯蒂芬直到几天后才知道这一切。
That's when Helen calls me up and says, I have something to tell you. And she tells me and I was floored by it. And together, we called my mom. And she put a good face on it, but she was pretty shocked.
那时海伦给我打电话说，我有件事要告诉你。她告诉我，我彻底惊呆了。我们一起给妈妈打了电话。她表现得很大度，但她其实非常震惊。
Did she know that there had been this other woman that your father had been in love with?
她知道你父亲曾经深爱过另一个女人吗？
That's the thing. My dad told her, years and years ago, there was this other woman that I was in love with at one point, long before I met you. But Mom was like, look, you have a past. I have a past. We all have a past. Who cares?
这就是问题所在。我爸爸多年前告诉过她，在他遇见你很久之前，我曾深爱过另一个女人。但我妈说，听着，你有过去。我有过去。我们都有过去。谁在乎呢？
Of course, never thinking that she was going to share grandchildren with that woman. She later admitted to me that if she had known this from the very beginning, she would have not supported Helen and me.
当然，她从没想过她会和那个女人共享外孙。她后来向我承认，如果她从一开始就知道这件事，她就不会支持我和海伦在一起了。
Really?
真的吗？
It would have just been like, look, being with the daughter of the other woman your dad loved-- it would-- can't you find someone else?
那会像是，听着，和你爸爸深爱过的女人的女儿在一起——这会——你就不能找别人吗？
How did you take this coincidence? Did it come to mean anything to you or to Helen?
你是怎么看待这个巧合的？这对你或海伦有什么意义吗？
Yeah. There's something about it-- the fact that I didn't have the time with my dad that I wished I had had.
是的。这其中有些东西——我没有和我爸爸相处足够多时间，这是我的遗憾。
Yeah.
是啊。
And then, suddenly, to have him be an active part of my life again. To think that I can talk to my mother-in-law and hear what he was like in his 20s-- something that my mom doesn't even know. And my-- actually, Helen's father is a strong believer in the idea that somehow my dad-- somehow is behind all this. That somehow he's helped make all this happen.
然后，突然之间，他再次成为我生活中积极的一部分。想到我可以和我岳母交谈，听听他20多岁时是什么样子——这是我妈妈都不知道的事情。事实上，海伦的父亲坚信，不知何故我爸爸在背后推动了这一切。不知何故是他促成了这一切的发生。
At the time this next love story takes place, a guy named Paul Grachan was working in a Chicago suburb called Arlington Heights. He had just started dating a woman named Esther. They'd been out maybe eight times.
在这个接下来的爱情故事发生时，一个叫保罗·格拉坎的家伙在芝加哥郊区阿灵顿高地工作。他刚开始和一个叫埃丝特的女人约会。他们大约约会了八次。
And I thought maybe it was time to get exclusive or become boyfriend/girlfriend or whatever it was. And I was about to go out to lunch and I was thinking about asking her on a Friday date that I had set up. And I went out to lunch. I stopped at the store prior to hitting the deli that I normally hit.
我想也许是时候确立排他性关系，成为男女朋友什么的了。我正要出去吃午饭，在考虑周五向她约会。我去吃午饭。去我常去的那家熟食店之前，我先在店里停了一下。
And I got some change, went to the deli, ordered my sandwich. It was $6 or something like that. I pulled out a $5 from my wallet and I pulled out the couple bucks' change that I had gotten from the store, handed the clerk one of the ones. And then I looked at it and I pulled it back.
我换了一些零钱，去了熟食店，点了三明治。大约6美元。我从钱包里掏出一张5美元的钞票，又掏出在店里换的那几美元零钱，递给店员一张一美元。然后我看了一眼，又把它抽了回来。
Written on the dollar, in pencil, was Esther. And I thought, oh, that's weird. I'm thinking about asking her to go steady and I get this dollar that says Esther on it. That's bizarre. So I stuck it in my pocket, chuckled.
钞票上用铅笔写着“埃丝特”。我想，哦，这太奇怪了。我正想着约她交往，就收到了这张写着埃丝特名字的钞票。这太离奇了。所以我把它揣进兜里，笑了笑。
I went to the store. I got one of those floating frames and a little piece of gold lame and I stuck the dollar in the frame. So it was floating in the middle on this piece of gold, as if you're going to go in a church in Italy and they had a fragment from the robe of some saint or something like that. And I called it the Immaculate Dollar of Arlington Heights.
我去了商店。我买了那种悬浮相框和一点金丝边，把钞票嵌在里面。它浮在金丝中央，就像你要去意大利的一座教堂，那里有某位圣人的长袍碎片之类的东西一样。我把它称为“阿灵顿高地的无暇之美元”。
So on Friday, I asked her out and she was all excited and we were all giddy. And then I said, hey, I have one more thing for you. And I gave her this frame with this dollar in it.
周五，我约她出来，她很兴奋，我们也都很激动。然后我说，嘿，我还有样东西给你。我把那个带相框的美元给了她。
I start unwrapping it and he's like, it's a dollar with your name on it. And he's all beside himself. And I just looked at him like, I'm freaked out.
我开始拆包装，他说，这是一张写着你名字的美元。他自己都惊呆了。我看着他，心想，我吓坏了。
She furrowed her brow a little bit and look concerned. And I said, is there some sort of problem?
她微微皱了皱眉，看起来很担心。我说，是有什么问题吗？
I was speechless for the first time ever. But I said, you know, remind me to tell you something later.
我有生以来第一次说不出话来。但我说，你知道，以后提醒我告诉你一件事。
So OK, I let it go and we had our relationship. We got engaged. We got married. A couple of years later, we were unpacking at a new apartment that we had. And I had the-- I found the frame with the dollar in it. And I stuck it up on the dresser and she came in the room. I said, hey, you never told me about this dollar. What's the deal with that? She said, well--
好吧，我没再问。我们继续交往。我们订婚了，结婚了。几年后，我们在新公寓里整理行李。我发现了那个嵌着美元的相框。我把它放在梳妆台上。她走进房间，我说，嘿，你从来没告诉过我关于这张美元的事。那是怎么回事？她说，嗯——
When I was 19, I was a cashier working in a copy shop in downtown Chicago. And I was dating someone and I just wasn't happy with him. And I just thought, how do people know who the right person that they're meant to be with-- how do they know who that is?
我19岁时，是芝加哥市中心一家复印店的出纳。当时我在和一个男人约会，但我并不开心。我心想，人们怎么知道谁是他们命中注定的那个人呢——他们怎么知道那个人是谁？
I said, you know what? I'm not going to worry about that. I'm just going to put my name on this dollar bill. And the guy that gets this dollar bill is going to be the guy that asks me to marry him.
我说，你知道吗？我不管这些了。我要把我的名字写在这张美元钞票上。拿到这张钞票的那个男人就是我要嫁的人。
And I'm like, well, you can't just write your name on one. Actually, I think it was more like maybe 10 or 12. And so this dollar bill that you gave me, I believe, is the same dollar bill that I wrote my name on. And I knew that we were going to be married the day that you gave me this dollar bill.
我心想，好吧，你不能只写一张。实际上，我想可能是10或12张。所以，我给你的这张美元钞票，我相信，就是我写上名字的那张。我给你这张钞票的那天，我就知道我们要结婚了。
It was pretty crazy.
这简直太疯狂了。
And then he made me tell him the story again. He asked me five or six times. And I said, the details don't change. It's the same story. He couldn't-- I think he was a little bit beside himself that that actually happened and that I didn't tell him.
然后他让我把故事又讲了一遍。他问了五六次。我说，细节没变。故事还是那个故事。他不能——我想他当时自己都惊呆了，这件事真的发生了，而且我没告诉他。
I don't know how I found the will to not say anything to him, but I just remember do I, don't I, do I, don't I? What do I do? I didn't want to freak this guy out and be like, what, this girl's already talking about marriage? Wait, what? Forget it.
我不知道我是怎么忍住没告诉他的，但我只记得在纠结，说还是不说，说还是不说？我该怎么办？我不想吓跑这家伙，如果让他觉得，什么，这女孩已经在谈婚论嫁了？等等，什么？算了吧。
I don't read too much into almost anything. I just kind of move forward. And then after she told me, I think I went through all the normal stages of whatever and I just thought, what does this mean for us? Are we going to invent a time machine or our kids going to bring world peace? What's the-- is there some sort of bigger thing that we're not seeing here?
我几乎不从这些事里解读出什么。我只是继续前进。她告诉我之后，我想我经历了所有正常的阶段，然后我想，这对我们意味着什么？我们要发明时光机还是我们的孩子会给世界带来和平？有什么更宏大的东西是我们没看到的吗？
Now it just sits in that very same frame up on our dresser and I look at it every day that I wake up. Sometimes I remind her that we have it when she's upset at me or angry.
现在它依然放在梳妆台那个相同的相框里，我每天醒来都会看看它。有时当她生我的气时，我会提醒她我们有这张钞票。
It's never been a question in my mind like, you know what? I'm going to kick this guy to the curb. But I do believe it's because of this dollar that I feel tied to him. Obviously, I love him, but I think that if it ever did cross my mind, I'd be like, but wait, this is my soulmate. I can't just walk out on him.
我从未想过，你知道吗？我要把这家伙踢开。但我确实相信是因为这张美元，我才感觉和他绑在一起。显然我爱他，但我想如果我曾有过离开他的念头，我会想，但等等，这是我的灵魂伴侣。我不能就这么离开他。
We don't even wear wedding bands. I'm like, why? I know I'm stuck with you. You got this dollar bill. I guess he could also put it back out into the register and then be like, look, I'm cashing this in. I think it's got to go to somebody else. He could do that.
我们甚至不戴婚戒。我说，为什么？我知道我被你缠住了。你有这张美元钞票。我想他也可以把它放回收银台，然后说，看，我把它兑现了。我想它该给别人了。他可以这么做。
Paul and Esther Grachan. They've been married for 18 years.
保罗和埃丝特·格拉坎。他们结婚18年了。
[MUSIC - "SOMEPLACE I'M SUPPOSED TO BE" BY BRY WEBB WITH RICH BURNETT]
[音乐 - "Someplace I'm Supposed to Be" by Bry Webb with Rich Burnett]
Act Three, Brother Can You Spare a Dime? This story comes from Ryan Rozar in Los Angeles.
第三幕，兄弟，能给点零钱吗？这个故事来自洛杉矶的瑞安·罗扎尔。
It happened when I was in college. I was actually pledging a fraternity. And I ran into some of the seniors on campus and they were laughing about something. And so one of them tells me this story that had happened to him that day, supposedly, where he gets in the shower and about 5, 10 minutes into his shower, he hears a "ting." And he looks down and sitting on the floor of the shower between his feet is a nickel. And has no idea where this nickel came from or why it's there.
发生在我上大学的时候。我当时正在预备加入一个兄弟会。我在校园里遇到几个大四学生，他们正在笑什么。其中一个人告诉了我他那天所谓发生的经历，他洗澡洗了5、10分钟，听到“叮”的一声。他低头一看，两脚之间的地板上躺着一枚镍币。他完全不知道这镍币是从哪儿来的，为什么会在那儿。
Obviously, everyone was making jokes that he had change falling out of his butt and we were like, were you eating dollar bills? But anyway, we have our laughs and I go home and I don't think much about it. The next day, I get in the shower and like 5, 10 minutes into my shower, I hear a "ting." And I look down and right between my feet is a quarter.
显然，大家都在开玩笑说他屁股里掉了零钱出来，我们问，你是不是在吃一美元钞票？总之，我们笑过了，我也回家了，没多想。第二天，我洗澡，5、10分钟后，听到“叮”的一声。我低头一看，两脚之间正好是一枚25美分硬币。
So my first thought was, how did they do it? My thought was, I totally assumed that this must not have really happened to him. That was a set up and somehow they set this up to happen to me. But I could not figure out how. I was just like, it had to be a prank, basically.
所以我的第一个想法是，他们是怎么做到的？我觉得这肯定不是真的发生在他身上。那是设计好的圈套，不知何故他们设置了这一切来整我。但我算不出怎么做到的。我只是觉得，这基本上是个恶作剧。
Oh, that's so smart of you to figure out the whole con.
哦，你真聪明，识破了整个骗局。
That's what I assumed.
我当时就是这么想的。
Right.
对。
But then I go and I talk to him I tell him what happened to me. And I'm watching his face for that-- the laugh or the glint in his eye of mischief or whatever.
但后来我去找他，告诉了他我身上发生的事。我在观察他的表情，看有没有那种笑意或者恶作剧的闪光什么的。
Right.
对。
And he just looks sincerely mystified by the fact that this happened to me right after it happened to him. Then a week later, I get in the shower and like 5, 10 minutes in, I hear "ting, ting." And I look down and there's about $0.35 between my feet. Right?
但他看起来真的很困惑，我不久前才发生的这件事，发生在他之后。然后一周后，我洗澡，洗了5、10分钟，听到“叮，叮”。我低头一看，两脚之间有大约35美分的零钱。对吧？
[SARAH LAUGHS]
[莎拉大笑]
So there's that moment of no way before I look down and there's more change. So at this point, obviously, my mind's going to some weird places because I-- you don't want to be the butt change fairy guy. There's somehow-- there's just-- there's nothing-- no way that this story gets good for me.
所以那一刻我还没来得及低头看就有了那种“不会吧”的想法，而且地上还有更多的零钱。此时此刻，显然我的头脑转向了一些奇怪的地方，因为你——你不想成为那个“屁股掉零钱的家伙”。这中间——没有任何——没有任何理由让这个故事对我有什么好结果。
And then no explanation comes, but it doesn't happen for a while-- for I want to say, probably, a month. Until one day, I'm about to get in the shower and I reach behind me to scratch my back and I feel something cold and metal on my back. And I turn around to show my-- to turn my back to the mirror--
然后并没有什么解释出现，但有一段时间——我想可能是一个月——没发生。直到有一天，我正要洗澡，伸手到背后挠痒，感觉背后有些冰凉的金属物。我转身展示我的——背对着镜子——
Right.
对。
And there is a whole pocketful of change stuck to my back?
一整口袋零钱粘在我的背上？
What do you mean stuck to it? In what way?
你是什么意思粘在上面？什么方式？
Stuck to it. Well, this is what I figured out. It wasn't-- there was no adhesive or anything. It was just impressed into my back. So I figured out what was going on is that I have a bad habit of falling asleep with my pants on because it was college, I would nap a lot. And I would also sleep with my shirt off because my apartment was really hot.
粘在上面。这就是我弄清楚的事情。它不是——没有胶水或什么东西。它只是压进了我的背部。所以我明白是怎么回事了，我有习惯穿着裤子睡觉，因为那时是大学，我经常打盹。而且我也经常光着上身睡觉，因为我的公寓很热。
So what was happening was change was falling out of my pockets onto my bed and I was laying on it and all that sweat and pressure was just sticking the coins to my back. They're just literally impressed into my back. And it was taking about five minutes of water running on it to dislodge them, at which point they were dropping at my feet.
发生的事情是零钱从我的口袋里掉到了床上，我躺在上面，所有的汗水和压力只是把硬币粘在了我的背上。它们真的就是压进了我的背部。花大约五分钟的水流冲洗，它们就会松动，然后落到我的脚边。
Clearly, I love this story, but I did not see the coincidence in it. Ryan said there was absolutely a coincidence. It happened to that one kid-- the senior-- and then it happened to him the very next day.
显然，我很喜欢这个故事，但我没看出其中的巧合。瑞安说那绝对是个巧合。它发生在那一个孩子——那个大四学生身上，然后第二天就发生在他身上。
I disagree. I think this is probably a common quirk of college boy life-- lounging around, shirtless and groggy, on unclean sofas and beds. Probably half the boys at his college had change stuck to them. I told Ryan so.
我不同意。我认为这可能是大学男生生活中常见的古怪行为——邋里邋遢地光着上身躺在不干净的沙发和床上。他大学里可能有一半男生身上粘着零钱。我告诉了瑞安。
I don't think there's any coincidence involved at all.
我不认为这有什么巧合。
I do because I'll tell you-- I've known lots of guys who've lived in pretty squalor conditions, and other than me and that other guy, I've never heard someone having the change falling from them.
我觉得有，因为我告诉你——我认识很多在相当贫困条件下生活的家伙，除了我和那个人，我从来没听说有人身上会掉零钱。
It's just because they're not admitting it. It's just because they're not admitting it. I swear to God. Start asking. Start asking.
那是因为他们没承认。仅仅是因为他们没承认。我发誓。开始问问吧。开始问问吧。
[KNOCK ON DOOR]
[敲门声]
Hello? Hi.
你好？嗨。
Hey, how's it going?
嘿，怎么样？
Good. Can I come in for a second?
很好。我能进去一会儿吗？
Yeah, sure.
当然可以。
I knew Ryan wouldn't actually start asking, so I started asking. Because while Ryan's life is sure to contain many special and unique experiences, I am positive that this is not one of them. So off I went to prove him wrong because finding others would be so easy. I happen to live in a college town-- State College, Pennsylvania, home of Penn State. So I drop by a frat house.
我知道瑞安不会真的开始问，所以我开始问了。因为虽然瑞安的生活肯定包含许多特殊而独特的经历，但我确信这不是其中之一。所以我去证明他是错的，因为找到其他人会很容易。我正好住在一个大学城——宾夕法尼亚州立大学所在地，宾夕法尼亚州州立学院。所以我路过一个兄弟会。
Has this ever happened to you?
这事发生在你身上过吗？
No, no. Absolutely not.
没有，没有。绝对没有。
Never in my life.
这辈子都没过。
Never?
从来没过？
Never in my life, no.
这辈子都没过，不。
Never? Never?
从来没？从来没？
Never.
从来没。
But wait, have you never heard of that happening to anybody?
等等，你从来没听说过这事发生在别人身上吗？
Not even close. Never heard of it.
差远了。从来没听说过。
What about you?
那你呢？
Never ever.
从来没有过。
Never?
从来没？
I think it'd be a nice icebreaker with women.
我觉得这会是个和女性聊天的不错开场白。
Why?
为什么？
Because in a conversation, you could be like, oh, this weird thing happened to me. Yeah. I always got change stuck to my back or my butt for weeks.
因为在交谈中，你可以说，哦，我身上发生了件怪事。是的。我有几周时间背上或屁股上总是粘着零钱。
Anyway, lots and lots of nos. I asked whole classes.
总之，很多很多否定的回答。我问了整个班级。
Has this happened to anyone?
这事发生在谁身上过吗？
No.
没有。
And then we thought, Pennsylvania, it's too cold. Ryan went to college in Southern California. We've got to go south. So we sent reporters to the University of Virginia.
然后我们想，宾夕法尼亚州，太冷了。瑞安在南加州读大学。我们得去南方。所以我们派记者去了弗吉尼亚大学。
All right. Have you heard of this happening?
好了。你听说过这事吗？
No.
没有。
I've never heard that before.
我以前从没听过。
No, none of us have had this happen.
没有，我们这儿没人发生过这种事。
No.
没有。
No, you're the first.
没有，你是第一个。
To frats at University of North Carolina.
去北卡罗来纳大学的兄弟会。
Never heard of that problem, no.
从来没听说过那问题，不。
All the way to Miami. We asked at two different universities there.
一直问到迈阿密。我们在那里两所不同的大学问了。
You never had it fall off in the shower?
你从来没在洗澡时掉出来过？
No. No. I can't say that it has.
没有。没有。我不能说有过。
No.
没有。
No, it's never happened. That's never happened to me.
没有，从来没发生过。那事从来没发生在我身上。
Never.
从来没有。
I've never heard of that happening to anybody till now, I guess.
直到现在，我猜，我从没听说过这种事发生在任何人身上。
Maybe it's a California thing? So we went to UCLA to match the climatological conditions at Ryan's school.
也许是加州特有的？所以我们去了加州大学洛杉矶分校，以匹配瑞安学校的气候条件。
Has it ever happened to you?
这事发生在你身上过吗？
No. That doesn't happen I don't think.
没有。我不觉得那事会发生。
Doesn't happen?
不会发生？
That's not a thing. That is not a thing.
那不是个事。那根本不是个事。
So does that mean Ryan was right-- it really was a coincidence? Maybe. I asked at one more class in Pennsylvania.
所以这意味着瑞安是对的——那真的是个巧合吗？也许吧。我在宾夕法尼亚州又问了一个班级。
Has this ever happened to any of you?
这事发生在你们任何人身上过吗？
Oh, it has. Oh, my god. Oh, my god.
哦，有过。天哪。天哪。
Ladies and gentlemen, Penn State senior, Casey Phillips.
女士们先生们，宾夕法尼亚州立大学大四学生，凯西·菲利普斯。
It's actually an ongoing joke in our apartment because there's just change in our shower all the time.
这实际上是我们公寓里的一个持续笑话，因为我们的淋浴间里总是有零钱。
And it's just from you, or others in your apartment, too?
只是你，还是公寓里的其他人也这样？
Just me. Actually there's change in my shower right now.
只有我。其实我的淋浴间里现在就有零钱。
Wait, what?
等等，什么？
There's a-- my roommate texted me today, why is there change in the shower? Because I forgot to take it out because that happens to me all the time. Like he said, I take naps all the time.
有一个——我的室友今天给我发短信说，为什么淋浴间里有零钱？因为我忘了把它拿出来，因为那经常发生在我身上。像他说的，我经常打盹。
I pretty much just sleep in naps-- in two-hour spurts. And I just sleep in my jeans and I have change in my jeans and it comes out and it gets in my bed. I figured it out the same way he did. That story was eerily similar.
我基本上就是打盹——两小时一次的间歇。我睡觉穿着牛仔裤，牛仔裤里有零钱，它就掉了出来，进了我的床。我弄清楚的方式和他一样。那个故事简直一模一样。
I am so pleased to meet you.
见到你真是太高兴了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I am too.
我也是。
Coming up, don't lift the manhole cover. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，不要掀开井盖。一分钟后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Sarah Koenig, sitting in for Ira Glass. We've borrowed today's show from a Chinese saying-- no coincidence, no story. We first aired the show four years ago after asking you to send us your coincidence stories. And you flooded us with more than 1,300 pitches. We found trends, we found gems, we found stories impossible to classify.
这是《美国生活》，我是莎拉·凯尼格，代班艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天借用了中国的一句老话——无巧不成书。我们在四年前首次播出这期节目，在邀请你们寄来巧合故事后，你们发来了超过1300个投稿。我们发现了趋势，发现了珍宝，发现了无法分类的故事。
My name's Jeff Dunn.
我叫杰夫·邓恩。
Jeff Dunn, OK.
杰夫·邓恩，好的。
Jeff grew up in Sioux City, Iowa. When he was 16, he was hanging out with two of his friends at someone's house. The parents weren't home-- they were goofing around, smoking pot. They were in the living room that had a huge window on one wall.
杰夫在爱荷华州苏城长大。16岁时，他和两个朋友在某人家里闲逛。父母不在家——他们在胡闹，抽大麻。他们坐在客厅里，墙上有一扇巨大的窗户。
And we're sitting there and we're sitting along this glass wall. And there's a dirt road outside of his house. And up this dirt road barrels this van. And the thing that happens next is what you think is going to happen when you see a white van like that at night.
我们坐在那儿，顺着玻璃墙坐着。他家外面是一条泥土路。一辆货车顺着泥土路飞驰而来。接下来发生的事，就是当你晚上看到那样的白货车时你以为会发生的事。
These two guys get out-- they're all bundled up and they pretty quickly just run to the back of the van, open it up, and pull out this big black bag. So they get out. They take the bag out. And they quickly run up this small hill that's behind his house.
两个家伙出来了——他们裹得很严实，很快跑到货车后面，打开门，拉出一个黑色大包。他们出来了。他们把包拿出来。很快跑上他家后面的一座小山。
And it's all wooded. There's no houses back there. So they run up this hill with this bag. And less than two minutes later, they come running back down. And they get in the van and they take off.
那里全是树林。后面没有房子。他们背着包跑上山。不到两分钟，他们又飞快跑下来。上了货车，开走了。
So Jeff and his friends do precisely what you don't want them to do. If this were an after school special, this is the point where you're yelling at the TV, saying, don't do it! Stay inside! But they decide they have to find out what the strange men in the van have deposited at the top of the hill. So they run up there.
所以杰夫和他的朋友们做了你绝对不想让他们做的事。如果这是一部课后特别节目，这会儿你肯定对着电视大喊，别去！留在屋里！但他们决定必须弄清楚货车里的怪人们在山顶存了什么。于是他们跑上去。
We get to the top and we look around. And then we see that on one side of it, there's this manhole cover-- like a circular manhole cover like you'd see anywhere. And coming from one of the edges of the manhole cover-- it's in place-- is long brown hair-- human hair.
我们到了顶端，四处看了看。然后我们看到一边有一个井盖——就像你随处可见的那种圆形井盖。在井盖边缘——它就在原位——露出一长条棕色的人类头发。
Long brown human hair. They are teenagers, they are stoned, they are freaked out. They have to tell an adult about what they've seen. A police car happens to drive by. They flag it down and the officer tells them to get in the back.
长长的棕色人类头发。他们是青少年，他们吸了毒，他们被吓坏了。他们必须告诉成年人他们看到了什么。一辆警车刚好路过。他们把它拦下，警察让他们上后座。
It became clear that she was really concerned because she then said, yeah, there's been a girl missing on the west side of town for the last couple days.
显而易见，她真的很担心，因为她说，是的，过去几天城西有一个女孩失踪了。
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
So again, our hearts just dropped.
所以我们的心又沉了下去。
And you hadn't known? That hadn't been on the news or something like that?
你当时不知道吗？新闻里没提过或者类似的事情？
We had no idea.
我们完全不知道。
You had no idea. OK.
你完全不知道。好吧。
So we just got scared at that point.
所以那时我们只是感到害怕。
Can I stop you for a second? Is this story going to get funny or is this a horrifying story? Wait, actually, don't tell me. Don't tell me.
我能打断你一下吗？这个故事会变好笑，还是个恐怖故事？等等，别告诉我。别告诉我。
I can't tell you.
我不能告诉你。
OK. Don't tell me.
好吧。别告诉我。
So she called another officer and the other officer comes. There's a couple cars. And they both get out and they tell us to get out and they say, OK, wait at the bottom of the hill. So we're waiting. They go walking up to the top. And it's dark, so we can't really see them that well.
她又叫了另一位警察，对方也来了。有几辆车。他们都下来告诉我们留在山脚下。我们在等。他们走上山顶。天很黑，我们看不清他们在做什么。
But we can see them well enough. And we don't really want to watch what's going on because we see them bend over, pull the cover off. And I'm trying not to look, but of course, I'm looking. And she pulls up a human figure out of the hole.
但我们看得够清楚。我们其实不想看发生了什么，因为我们看到他们弯下腰，掀开盖子。我尽量不看，但当然，我还在看。她从洞里拉出了一个人形物体。
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
And then she says, it's a mannequin. I don't know what my friends were thinking, but I was sitting there thinking, how does this story end up OK? And it doesn't in any universe unless you say, it's a mannequin.
然后她说，这是个模特。我不知道我朋友们在想什么，但我当时心想，这故事怎么才能有好结局？除非你说，这是个模特，否则在任何宇宙里它都没办法解决。
[SARAH LAUGHS]
[莎拉大笑]
Jeff goes to school on Monday, tells his story in physics class, and the kid next to him says, that was us. We did it. We went around stealing holiday decorations and we had to get rid of them so we stuffed them under the manhole cover. The mannequin, by the way, had been the Virgin Mary in someone's nativity scene.
杰夫周一上学，在物理课上讲了这个故事，旁边的孩子说，那是我们干的。我们干的。我们到处偷节日装饰品，必须处理掉它们，所以我们就把它们塞进了井盖下面。顺便说一下，那个模特就是某人耶稣诞生场景里的圣母玛利亚。
I think the real coincidence is that it's our close friends that caused this to happen to us.
我认为真正的巧合是，是我们亲密的朋友导致这事发生在我们身上。
Oh, they were good friends of yours.
哦，他们是你很好的朋友。
Yeah.
是啊。
Right. Right.
对。对。
No, Jeff. Turns out that is not the real coincidence of the story. My producer Brian Reed was listening to all these interviews as they were happening and he interrupted us to tell us we both missed the point. Brian's just pointed out that I'm missing-- you and I are both missing the big coincidence.
不，杰夫。事实证明那不是这个故事真正的巧合。我的制片人布莱恩·里德在采访发生时一直在听，他打断我们说我们都弄错了重点。布莱恩刚才指出我错过了——你和我都没看出那个大巧合。
I don't even know the coincidence of my own story. Yeah, I submitted it to the coincidences thing.
我甚至不知道我自己的故事里有什么巧合。是的，我把它提交给那个巧合节目了。
So the main coincidence is there's a girl missing at the same time.
所以主要的巧合是同时有一个女孩失踪了。
Yeah.
是的。
I have five words for you, Jeff.
杰夫，我有五个字送给你。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
No coincidence, no story.
无巧不成书。
Here's a definition of coincidence that seems right to me. A coincidence is a surprising concurrence of events perceived as meaningfully related with no apparent causal connection. It's that middle part-- meaningfully related-- that people seem to get stuck on.
这是一个我觉得对巧合很准确的定义。巧合是一系列令人惊讶的事件并发，被感知为意义相关，但没有任何明显的因果联系。正是中间那一部分——“意义相关”——人们似乎卡住了。
Because when events line up just so, you can't help it. You can't help but wonder if there's a message in that. In that way, coincidences are like shortcuts to very big questions about fate, about God, even to people who don't believe in either one.
因为当事件刚好凑在一起时，你无法抗拒。你忍不住想知道这其中是否有什么信息。从这个角度看，巧合就像通往关于命运、上帝等宏大问题的捷径，即使是对那些两者都不信的人来说也是如此。
The notion that somewhere out there, someone or something is paying attention to your life-- that there might be a plan conjured through coincidences-- that notion seems to be most appealing when you're young. We got one story about a young couple visiting Marrakesh in Morocco. They're at a restaurant talking, like you do, about old flames. And the boyfriend wanted to know about one guy in particular.
那种认为在某个地方，某人或某物正在关注你的生活——那种认为通过巧合可能存在某种计划——这种观念似乎在年轻人中最为吸引人。我们收到一个关于一对在摩洛哥马拉喀什度假的年轻情侣的故事。他们在餐馆聊天，谈论旧爱，就像你们常做的那样。男朋友想知道关于一个特定男人的事。
I asked, Kate, Kate, what did this guy look like? And Kate just stopped dead in her tracks and lifted one hand to her mouth, with the other hand pointed across the restaurant. And she said, oh, my god. He looked like that. And she crossed the restaurant and tapped him on the back of the shoulder. And it was him.
我问，凯特，凯特，那个男人长什么样？凯特整个人僵住了，一只手捂住嘴，另一只手指向餐厅对面。她说，天哪。他看起来就是那样。她穿过餐厅，拍了拍他的肩膀。真的是他。
The daughter of a jazz guitarist named Andy Riley wrote to us about the time when she was 19. She was listening to an Ella Fitzgerald album.
一位爵士吉他手安迪·莱利的女儿写信给我们，讲了她19岁时的一件事。她在听埃拉·费茨杰拉德的专辑。
I was listening to the song, "That Old Black Magic." And at the end of the song, Ella throws in a line, "that old black magic that Billy Daniels got me in." And I've heard her sing that line on that album dozens of times before and wondered, who's Billy Daniels?
我在听那首《That Old Black Magic》。在歌曲结尾，埃拉加入了一句歌词，“that old black magic that Billy Daniels got me in”。我以前在这张专辑里听她唱过无数次这句歌词，心想，比利·丹尼尔斯是谁？
But on this particular day, for some reason, I felt inspired to go out to the living room and ask my dad who Billy Daniels was. And he explained that in the '40s, Billy Daniels had sung "Old Black Magic" in a way that made it his song. And he was referred to as Mr. Black Magic, I guess, back in the '40s. And it was a big deal at the time.
但在这一天，出于某种原因，我感觉受到启发，走到客厅问我爸比利·丹尼尔斯是谁。他解释说，在40年代，比利·丹尼尔斯唱过《Old Black Magic》，唱出了属于他自己的风格。在40年代，他被称为“黑魔法先生”，我想是这样。在当时那是件大事。
And I asked my dad, had you met him? Did you ever know Billy Daniels? And he said that Billy Daniels was probably dead now.
我问我爸，你见过他吗？你认识比利·丹尼尔斯吗？他说比利·丹尼尔斯现在大概已经死了。
And literally at that moment, the phone rang. So I answer the phone. And this playful, gravelly voice asked for Andy Riley. And I said, who's calling? And he said, Billy Daniels.
就在那一刻，电话响了。我接了电话。一个俏皮、沙哑的声音询问安迪·莱利。我说，谁在打？他说，比利·丹尼尔斯。
So, last September, I was living in Roswell, New Mexico. And I had woken up in jail for the last time.
去年9月，我住在新墨西哥州的罗斯韦尔。我最后一次在监狱醒来。
This is Etta Thordarson. When this happened, she was 20 years old, on drugs, hanging out with street kids. Her mom offered to buy her a bus ticket to Washington state to go to rehab. Etta said, yes.
这是埃塔·索达森。这件事发生时，她才20岁，吸毒，和街头少年混在一起。她妈妈提出给她买一张去华盛顿州接受戒毒治疗的车票。埃塔答应了。
She took her dog and got on the bus. In Los Angeles, there was a stopover at the depot and this guy comes up to her while she's waiting in line to get food. She's got $2-- just enough for some French fries. The guy starts asking her questions about her dog.
她带着狗上了车。在洛杉矶车站转车时，她排队等食物时，一个男人向她走来。她身上有2美元——刚好够买点炸薯条。那人开始问她关于狗的问题。
And he starts asking me other random questions, like, what are you doing? Where are you going? And then he asks me, are you from Alaska?
他开始问我其他一些随机问题，比如，你在做什么？你要去哪儿？然后他问我，你是阿拉斯加人吗？
And I was like, yeah, I am, actually. And then he asked me, is your mom named Meg? And I was like, mm-hmm. Yeah. She is.
我说，是的，确实。然后他问我，你妈妈叫梅格吗？我说，嗯嗯。是的。她是。
And he was like, oh, well-- well, I'm Chris. I'm your father. I met you 10 years ago. And I was like, oh, holy [BEEP].
他说，哦，嗯——我是克里斯。我是你父亲。我10年前见过你。我说，噢，该死的[哔]。
Etta had only seen her father that one time, briefly, when she was 11.
埃塔只在那次见过她父亲，那是她11岁时短暂的一次。
And then he pulls out a big wad of money and he pays for my food. And then he hands me $40. And was like, don't say I never gave you nothing and walked away.
然后他掏出一大把钱，为我的食物买了单。然后递给我40美元。说，别说我没给过你什么，然后走开了。
That-- what-- I-- I'm shocked by this story. And he didn't-- that was it? You didn't see him again? He didn't--
这——什么——我——我被这个故事震惊了。他就——那是全部吗？你没再见过他？他没——
No. You could tell he felt bad.
没有。你能看出他觉得不好意思。
Did you expect something more to happen? Did you think, oh, well, here's how this is going to go.
你期待发生更多事吗？你觉得，哦，好了，这事要这样发展了。
Yeah. I really thought we were going to go sit down and eat together and I was going to lay out my whole life story for him and he was going to explain his life and where he's been. I was looking forward to that. But it didn't happen. Mostly, I want to study his face for longer just because that's-- I've seen him twice and I still can't really remember what he looks like.
是的。我真的以为我们会坐下来一起吃饭，我要对他讲述我整个人生故事，他会解释他的生活以及他去了哪儿。我很期待。但那没发生。大部分时间，我只是想更长时间地观察他的脸，因为——我只见过他两次，我还是记不住他长什么样。
Do you regret not pursuing him in some way?
你后悔没有以某种方式去寻找他吗？
Yeah, absolutely. In the moment, I was just-- I was so sick. I just really couldn't comprehend. It wasn't until I got on the bus that I was just-- why didn't I run after him? I've just spent my whole life wondering about this man and the chance to talk to him was put right in front of my face and I didn't really understand that at the time. And I let it go.
是的，绝对后悔。那一刻，我只是——我太糟糕了。我真的无法理解。直到我上了车我才——我为什么没追他？我整辈子都在好奇这个男人，谈话的机会就摆在我的面前，当时我没真正意识到。我让他走了。
Emiliana Garcia-Sarnoff also hadn't seen his father in many years, since he was seven or eight years old. He lived in California, but he was visiting a national park in Mexico with his mother when he was 18 and they hiked to the top of a pyramid there. The whole place was sort of off the beaten track.
艾米利亚娜·加西亚-萨诺夫也很多年没见过父亲了，从他七八岁开始。他住在加州，但他18岁时和母亲去墨西哥的一家国家公园游玩，他们徒步爬上了那里的金字塔顶端。那个地方基本上远离尘世。
We were walking along and some people passed in front of us and my mom said, oh, my god. Raul? And then she turned to me and said, that's your father. That's your dad. And it was.
我们走着走着，有人从我们前面经过，我妈说，噢，天哪。劳尔？然后她转向我说，那是你父亲。那是你爸爸。真的是。
Also, coincidentally, it was Father's Day.
而且巧合的是，那天正好是父亲节。
I ended up, embarrassingly, breaking down and crying on that pyramid. It was a really emotional moment for me. My father definitely-- his absence meant a lot to me. And we said, yeah, we're going to stay in contact.
我最后尴尬地在那个金字塔上崩溃大哭。对我来说那是一个非常感性的时刻。我父亲确实——他的缺席对我意义重大。我们说，是的，我们要保持联系。
And after they said bye, they left. And he came running back up the hill about 20 minutes later. And you could hear him panting. And he said, Emiliano, I just want to say I'm sorry that I didn't stay in touch and that I love you. And he turned and went back down the hill.
告别后，他们离开了。大约20分钟后，他跑回了山上。你能听到他气喘吁吁。他说，艾米利亚诺，我只是想说我很抱歉我没保持联系，我爱你。然后他转身走下了山。
Emiliano's story goes the way Etta wishes hers had gone. After a rocky few years, he and his father did get to know each other and each other's families. Emiliano had a son who now had a grandfather. Emiliano's father had left him when he was a baby, but when his father died some years ago, Emiliano was there at the hospital. They'd had a real relationship and that never would have happened, Emiliano said, if he hadn't seen him that day at the pyramid.
艾米利亚诺的故事走向了埃塔所希望的那个方向。经过几年的坎坷，他和父亲确实了解了对方，也了解了对方的家庭。艾米利亚诺有了一个儿子，现在也有了祖父。艾米利亚诺的父亲在他婴儿时期就离开了他，但当他父亲几年前去世时，艾米利亚诺在医院。他们建立了一段真正的关系，艾米利亚诺说，如果那天在金字塔没见到他，这一切永远不会发生。
Walking down that pyramid, I was talking out loud to myself. And I was saying-- this is one strong memory I have. I was saying, don't forget, don't forget. Just getting angry with my future self, which I knew would rationalize this event.
走下金字塔时，我在自言自语。我说——这是一个我记忆很深的时刻。我说，别忘了，别忘了。只是对自己未来的自我感到愤怒，因为我知道未来会把这件事合理化。
Because I had a very distinct sense that I had felt that this was definitely a miracle. Something had intervened and brought us together. You don't just run into your father on top of a pyramid. So I think I was a believer for about a week. And then--
因为我有一种非常清晰的感觉，我觉得这绝对是一个奇迹。有什么力量干预并让我们聚在一起。你不会就那样在金字塔顶端撞见你父亲。所以我想我大概相信了一周。然后——
And then, that very pause--
然后，那短暂的暂停——
That brings us to Act Five, What Are the Chances? In order to let a good coincidence live a long and healthy life-- to get told and retold and take its rightful place in the narrative of your life-- sometimes you have to stop yourself from thinking it all the way through-- why it happened, really. Because the fact is, any statistician will probably rain on your parade, will tell you these things happen a lot more often than you think.
这把我们带到了第五幕，“概率是多少？”为了让一个好的巧合拥有长久而健康的生命——被讲述、再讲述，并在你的人生叙事中占据应有的位置——有时你必须阻止自己想得太透彻——它为什么发生，真正的原因。因为事实是，任何统计学家都可能会破坏你的兴致，会告诉你这些事情发生的频率比你想象的要多得多。
But a good coincidence is like a good magic trick. When you see one, a struggle ensues instantaneously between the thrill of the apparent miracle and the urge to debunk it. This final story is by Kerry Weeks. He's a prop guy for the movies, but he told this at a storytelling competition.
但一个好的巧合就像一个好的魔术。当你看到一个时，那种对看似奇迹的兴奋感和想要揭穿它的冲动之间会立刻爆发一场斗争。这个最后的故事来自凯瑞·威克斯。他是电影道具师，但在一次故事比赛中讲述了这个故事。
Here's my story. I'm nine years old-- first time going to summer camp. And my grandfather gives me-- before I go, he gives me his old pocket knife. It's practically an antique. And so the first thing all of us boys do when we get to camp is we pull out our knives and we start throwing them at things, trying to get them to stick the way Daniel Boone did. And because it's the 1970s, there's nothing unusual about a bunch of young children throwing sharp knives around.
这是我的故事。我9岁——第一次去夏令营。在我出发前，祖父给了我一把他的旧折叠刀。它简直是个古董。我们男孩到营地的第一件事就是掏出刀子朝东西扔，试图模仿丹尼尔·布恩把它扎住。因为那是20世纪70年代，一群小孩乱扔尖刀没什么不寻常的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I got mine to stick in the floorboard. It was like, "wong." And it was great. But when I pulled it out, the tip broke off.
我把它扎进了地板上。感觉像“嗡”。太棒了。但当我把它拔出来时，刀尖断了。
But anyway, camp goes on. And a few days later, I notice my knife is missing. And I look everywhere for it. I look high, I look low. It's gone.
总之，夏令营继续。几天后，我发现刀丢了。我到处找。我找了高处，找了低处。它没了。
But then one day, I'm walking through camp and I see this group of boys throwing knives at a tree and something tells me I should check this out. And sure enough, there's this boy in there throwing my knife. Now, there's no mistaking this knife because the handle was red and green, but the colors met in the middle and kind of swirled together in a trippy, psychedelic way. And I've never seen a knife like that before or since.
但有一天，我走在营地里，看到一群男孩在朝树扔刀子，有什么东西告诉我该去看看。果然，有个男孩在扔我的刀。现在，这把刀没法认错，因为刀柄是红绿色的，但在中间汇合，以一种迷幻的、疯疯癫癫的方式旋转着。我从未见过那样的刀。
So I walk up to this boy. He's a little older, but I walk up to him and I say, hey, that's my knife. And he says, no, it's mine. And I say, no, that's my knife. My grandfather gave it to me. And he says, no, he didn't.
所以我走向那个男孩。他稍微大一点，但我走过去说，嘿，那是我的刀。他说，不，那是我的。我说，不，那是我的刀。我祖父给我的。他说，没有，他没给。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He says, my grandfather gave it to me. And I'm confused all of a sudden. Maybe I should have thought this through a bit more. I thought he would just hand it over. And the other boys-- they move in close. And I'm thinking, could it be possible that his grandfather gave him the exact same knife that my grandfather gave me? Is this a thing and I just didn't know it?
他说，我祖父给我的。我突然困惑了。也许我应该稍微想清楚一点。我以为他会直接交出来的。其他男孩——他们围了过来。我在想，难道他的祖父真的给了他和我祖父给我的完全一样的刀吗？这东西很普遍而我不知道吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But I look at the knife he's holding in his hand and I look at the blade and I see that the tip of the blade is squared off, as though it were broken. And I say, that's my knife because I broke the tip off when I stuck it in the floor. And he says, what, that? No, it came that way so you can use it like a screwdriver.
但我看了看他手里拿着的刀，看了看刀刃，看到刀尖是方的，就像它断了一样。我说，那就是我的刀，因为我把它扎在地板上时把刀尖弄断了。他说，什么，这个？不，它买来就是这样，你可以把它当螺丝刀用。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I look at the other boys and I'm not getting any help from them. And so I wander off, just thinking to myself, screwdriver. I never thought of that.
我看着其他男孩，没得到任何帮助。所以我走开了，心里想，螺丝刀。我从没想过。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Well, as you can imagine, this really bugged me. And I don't mean just while I was at camp, but for the rest of my life.
嗯，正如你可以想象的那样，这真的困扰了我。我不只是指在夏令营期间，而是我余生都受此困扰。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And I kept thinking, why did I fold so easily? Why didn't I go to the counselors? And the only thing I can think of is this.
我一直想，为什么我退缩得这么容易？为什么我不去找辅导员？唯一能想到的只有这个。
I'm the son of a physicist. And I used to ask my dad these questions all the time like, Dad, how far away is the sun? Dad, how fast is the speed of light? Dad, what's the closest star? And he would give me these answers and these numbers that were just so [BEEP] huge, I couldn't get my mind around them.
我是物理学家的儿子。我过去常问我爸这些问题，比如，爸，太阳有多远？爸，光速有多快？爸，最近的恒星是什么？他会给出答案和一些数字，那些数字简直[哔]太巨大了，我根本无法理解。
So my point is this. I, better than most other children, had an idea of just how vast the universe is.
所以我的观点是这个。我，比大多数孩子更有想法，知道宇宙是多么广阔。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And therefore, how infinite the possibilities are. So the thing is, at the time, I thought, well, maybe the kid's telling the truth. The only reason why I bring this up is because this is what I was thinking of when, some 32 years later, I become the landlord of a small apartment building. And one of the first things I did as a landlord was I threw this guy out because he was a small time drug dealer.
因此，可能性是无限的。所以事实是，当时我心想，好吧，也许那孩子说的是真话。我提起这件事的唯一原因是因为当32年后，我成为一栋小型公寓楼的房东时，我脑子里想的也是这个。我做房东做的第一件事就是把这家伙赶走，因为他是个小毒贩。
On the day he's moving out, I get a call from his neighbor across the hall-- a guy I call Budweiser Bob. And Budweiser Bob says, hey, that druggie is stealing your refrigerator.
在他搬走那天，我接到了他隔壁邻居的电话——我叫他“百威鲍勃”。百威鲍勃说，嘿，那个瘾君子在偷你的冰箱。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And so I hop down there. And sure enough, in the driveway is a pickup truck. And in the back of the pickup truck is a refrigerator.
于是我冲了过去。果然，车道上一辆皮卡车。皮卡车后面是一个冰箱。
So I charge up the stairs and I demand to know just what the hell is going on. And Nick, the druggie, calmly tells me-- he says, dude, when I moved in here, that refrigerator was so gross, I bought my own refrigerator and swapped it out. And I put that one in storage. And now I'm just putting it back.
所以我冲上楼梯，质问到底是怎么回事。尼克，那个瘾君子，冷静地告诉了我——他说，兄弟，我搬进来时，那冰箱太恶心了，我就买了台自己的冰箱换了上去。我把那台冰箱存起来了。现在我只是把它放回去。
And I look in the kitchen. And sure enough, there's another refrigerator. It's a little old, a little dirty, but it's working.
我看了看厨房。果然，那里还有另一台冰箱。稍微旧了点，有点脏，但能用。
And I'm trying to think this through. Would someone really go to all that trouble of just swapping out a refrigerator and then putting it in storage and bringing it back? Or would a guy go to the trouble of stealing a used refrigerator just to screw his landlord and replacing it with an even more used refrigerator?
我试着想清楚这件事。真的有人会费劲去换一台冰箱，然后存起来，再带回来吗？或者有人会费心去偷一台旧冰箱只是为了折磨他的房东，然后换上一台更旧的冰箱吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And well, the answer to both these questions is yes.
答案是，这两个问题的答案都是肯定的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But I look up, and there's Nick. And he's expecting me to say something. And there's his buddies, who are helping him move. And they're expecting me to say something. So I walk up to Nick and I look him in the eye and I say to him, you sweep up real good before you leave.
但我也抬头看了，尼克在那儿。他等着我说什么。还有帮他搬家的伙伴们。他们等着我说什么。所以我走向尼克，看着他的眼睛说，你走之前把地打扫干净。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Because there's just too many possibilities in this universe. Thank you.
因为这个宇宙里的可能性实在太多了。谢谢。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Kerry Weeks lives in New York. His story was recorded live at a Moth story slam in New York City. You can download the Moth podcast on iTunes or wherever you get your podcasts.
凯瑞·威克斯住在纽约。他的故事是在纽约市的一次Moth故事大赛现场录制的。你可以在iTunes或其他获取播客的地方下载Moth播客。
At the beginning of the show, I said I was a skeptic. But after talking to so many people about coincidences-- including a Stanford mathematician who spent decades studying them-- I end up here, agreeing with this one woman I interviewed about her coincidence. She knew her story could probably be explained away with statistics and probability. But she said, there's just a poetry to things like this when they happen. There's some kind of beauty in it. There's meaning in the noticing of it at all.
节目开始时，我说我是个怀疑论者。但在和这么多人聊过巧合之后——包括一位研究巧合几十年的斯坦福数学家——我最终得出了结论，同意我采访的那位女士对她巧合事件的评价。她知道她的故事大概可以用统计学和概率论解释掉。但她说，当这些事情发生时，其中有一种诗意。这其中有一种美感。即使只是注意到这些本身就很有意义。
[MUSIC - "CHILDREN OF COINCIDENCE" BY DORY PREVIN]
[音乐 - "Children of Coincidence" by Dory Previn]
Our program was produced today by Brian Reed and me, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Senior producer for this episode was Julie Snyder. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Production help from Emmanuel Dzotsi and Diane Wu. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Music help from Damian Graef and Rob Geddis.
我们的节目今天由布莱恩·里德和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、三木·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。本集的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。制作协助来自伊曼纽尔·佐齐和黛安·吴。塞斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗布·盖迪斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our original music about the immaculate dollar was written and performed by Bry Webb and Rich Burnett, produced by Bry and Jeff McMurrich. His website, brywebb.com. Our website is thisamericanlife.org, where, this week, we have extra coincidence stories from you that all involve your photographs. That's at thisamericanlife.org.
我们关于无暇之美元的原创音乐由布莱·韦伯和里奇·伯内特创作并演奏，由布莱和杰夫·麦克默里奇制作。他的网站，brywebb.com。我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org，本周我们在网站上提供了你们额外投稿的巧合故事，都涉及你们的照片。地址是thisamericanlife.org。
Thanks also to Torey Malatia, who's on vacation with Ira this week. They were so excited for their cruise, but it seems like by day three, the fun is starting to fade.
也感谢托里·马拉蒂亚，他本周和艾拉一起休假。他们对游轮非常兴奋，但看起来到第三天，快乐开始消退了。
You are impossible to argue with. So when you ask, you are so set in you ways.
你真是让人无法辩驳。所以当你询问时，你太固执己见。
I'm 81. OK. Yeah, OK.
我81岁了。好吧。是的，好吧。
I'm Sarah Koenig. Ira Glass will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是莎拉·凯尼格。艾拉·格拉斯下周将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。